salut à tous ici envergure vous nous
connaissez maintenant l'espère si vous
découvrez sachez qu'on parle des jeunes
joueurs de basketball et que évidemment
notre mais ça nous c'est la draft c'est
bientôt ce mois de juillet fin juillet
alors on va se poser une question si
vous intéressez un petit peu à la cuvée
de draft qui arrive vous avez sans doute
entendu parler de kate cunningham et si
kyle cunningham n'était pas le meilleur
joueur de cette draft ça va être notre
question fil rouge dans ce podcast
puisque nous allons parler de celui qui
est vu presque unanimement comme le
numéro 2 le deuxième meilleur joueur de
la cuvée draft nba 2021 nouvel épisode à
landen là nous sommes allés sur phil
ochs c'est parti
comment ça va messieurs ça va très bien
toi parfaitement bien
très très bien très proche maintenant la
loterie on enregistre on enregistre
voilà on enregistre le 21 juin
le podcast sortira le 23 donc la loterie
sera déjà passé ça va pas changer
énormément de choses à nos podcasts du
soir en tout cas on va faire en sorte
que toujours est il que la voilà il ya
le g-league combined où je sais pas
comment ils l'appellent le jilin kent
ensuite il ya la loterie ensuite il ya
le nba combined et ensuite il ya la
draft un mois plus tard 29 juillet on va
être là tout au long de tout au long de
ces rendez vous on vous conseille pour
ce podcast d'ouvrir le site envergure
vous pouvez aller voir notre dernier big
board c'est à dire le classement des
joueurs qu'on pense être les meilleurs
dans l'ordre évidemment delà de la
prochaine cuvée
et puis la fiche des vannes mobley vous
aurez ses stades ses mensurations et le
scouting report
écrit par benoît lelièvre ici présents
ben j'aimerais que tu me parle déjà de
la vie de l'oeuvre des vannes mobley
avant de parler de son jeu
elle va de meubles est déjà le seul fils
de joie papa mobley ya joué un peu en
nba mais surtout en europe
donc on parle ici d'un joueur qui est
vraiment le grand talent dans le giron
du sport avec mon frère on oublie il est
il est candidat il ya il a un an de plus
mais c'est pas pris un agent on lisse et
laisser le choix de revenir pour
l'instant et que c'est quoi c'est ce que
c'est ce que je croyais ça fait très
très longtemps qu'evan mon blé est
réputé et un peu discuté par les paroles
et spire du futur de la nba je crois que
je moi je les attendais pas déplu la
première fois 13 14 joueurs qu'un
parcours quand même très intéressant
parce que jusqu'à l'année dernière je
vous dirais que personnellement j'ai pas
vrai je ne voyais pas vraiment avec lui
ce genre de joueur qui qui se contentait
de finir par dessus tout le monde à
l'école qui trottait de gauche à droite
sur le terrain mais cette année on l'a
forcé à jouer au basket
puis on a vu le bon on en discutera plus
tôt plus en détail dans le parc dans le
podcast pour le but de bien belles
choses mais surtout
ou surtout des développements très
rapide une très belle amélioration
manu au niveau du parcours high school
et hey you fin prêt nba puisqu'il était
un jouet ayew ainsi donc cette année ça
o vernhe california qu'est ce que c'est
il est passé par des gros lycées etc
qu'est ce que tu peux nous dire
là-dessus non pas decroly chez un amas
connaissent moi je l'avais regardé on
sait dès le lycée de son quartier quoi
il a pas fait la preuve tout comme
d'autres ont pu faire ou en faire oui le
ran show christiane schools septembre
c'est un jeune homme qui a quitté sa
communauté il est de californie ben oui
il vient d'un peu de droit californie je
crois donc donc il n'est pas parti très
loin que ce soit pour le s cube le high
school pardon ou pour la fac donc y eut
aussi cette saison je vais vous donner
rapidement des stats brute même si je
rappel vous pouvez les avoir sous les
yeux sur notre site
16 points de moyenne presque 9 rebonds
plus de deux passes décisives un peu
plus de passes décisives que deux balles
perdues d'ailleurs quasiment 3 contres
de moyenne et surtout ce qui est
intéressant toujours ce sont les
pourcentages puisque même s'ils jouaient
34 minutes par match donc c'est pas mal
mais pour les stats avant c'est plus
intéressant qu'il a quasiment 9 % 2
contre ça veut dire que quand il était
sur le terrain il compterait neuf tirs
adverses sur 100 quasiment donc ce qui
est beaucoup
les élites sont à dix mais c'est
vraiment les élite élite élite pain de
anthony davis et ses 9 9% ce pas mal et
sinon rebondeur plutôt correct correct
plus sur tout rebond offensif
bon passeur pas trop de balles perdues
et un taux d'usagé puisque ça c'est
intéressant aussi qui est pas
extrêmement haut on va en parler
d'ailleurs avec alan comment il était
utilisé
ayew à 6 avant de parler de ses qualités
ses défauts mal famés c'est parce que
ces jours-ci mais toi tu vas en règle le
monde soit exposé angie league comme ça
avec les points forts non non je n'en
ont même pas une fois mais j'aimerais
qu'ils aient au moins un minimum de gars
qui peut le servir sur un pick and pop
quoi ce qui n'a pas été le cas s'il a
été assez peu le cas cette année
ayew aussi cessé mais c'était un peu
comme ce qui se passait l'an passé que
une école kong ou en fait c'est des
intérieurs qui ont besoin de la crabe
alors qu'on vous bien plus que mobley
les meubles est quand même parce que en
les jeux les plus simples pour qu'un
intérieur puisse peser c'est quand même
sur du pick and roll et donc pas sûr du
picking up ou alors sur de l'attak de
cercle poste pour usage d'écran il faut
quand même une bonne passe ou un intérêt
ou un acteur qui joue positivement le
pick and roll et c'est vrai qu'ils
arrivent aussi ce n'était pas tellement
le cas donc il était utilisé
offensivement on lui demandait de faire
pas mal de choses et ça au mans 7e place
intéressant parce qu'on l'a vu dribbles
et on l'a vu posté on l'a vu tout est un
petit peu quand on l'a pris même si
j'aime que j'aurais aimé le voir plus on
l'a vu faire pas toutes les choses qui
font qu'aujourd'hui devrait doubler et
pressantes présentées comme le deuxième
meilleur joueur de cette drogue
donc comme c'est un intérieur si
aujourd'hui est présenté comme le
deuxième meilleur jour de ma grave c'est
parce que il a montré une capacité et
une diversité offensive de grande
envergure dire qu'il est capable de été
capable de poser des écrans tirez pas
ses dribbles et ce qui est à son âge à
sa taille reste quand même super super
impressionnant défensivement à la nuit
ya pas mal de zones lui aussi de dans ma
tête
ouais il est
pas très très vite et n'était jamais
très très loin du cercle on va dire non
je vais très très loin du cercle moi
j'ai un point noir c'est le rebond même
si les stats sont pas atroce il rattrape
avec le rebond offensif on va dire mais
c'est vrai que les stats de rendement
défensif sont pas du tout excellente
pour un joueur de sa taille stade de
rebond des fois t'es voilà ça sur le
rebond défensif il se faisait un peu de
tanguay souvent c'est pas c'est pas
tellement de questions et lectures ou
une question de on appelle ça de termini
qualité ouais c'est ça ou de deux
lectures de réponse à une lecture c'est
plus que vaille contre des mains contre
des intérieurs plus petit mais plus
puissant ou non les intérêts de certains
devront plus puissant et ses fils
faisait souvent prenait rebond un peu
dessus mais ça c'est plus il ya un
développement physique et surtout
musculaire qui va se faire dans les
prochaines années je pense ma nuque elle
quel point fort tu donnerais à evans mob
lesquels s à sa carte de visite pour la
draft
au delà de enfin peut-être développer ce
qu a esquissé à l'âne
moi ce qui me fait ce qui m'a fait
utilité le échanger mon regard sur lui
c'est son jeu de passe j'ai vraiment
apprécié ça
cette capacité à trouver des bonnes
parce que soient intérieurs et
extérieurs et c'est vraiment 5 qui pour
moi le fait venir un joueur au dessus
des autres et le mont numéro 2 sur mon
big band
parce que il s'est peu pour pouvoir
faire une passe ça veut dire qu'on
attire la défense on a juste parlé j'ai
même pas donné sa taille fed fait de
mettre 13 500 seven footer il est très
léger il doit plus faire 93 kg comme
c'est marqué sur notre site mais doit
être moins de 100 kg quand même voilà
comment il fait des différences mais je
vois ce que j'aime bien c'est jay il a
une bonne lecture du jeu je trouve donc
c'est vraiment ça il est pas il n'est
pas obnubilé par par le panier il va
tout de suite même si les joue parfois
loin du cercle
il arrive à trouver il va pas être y
restent ouverts je vais shooter parce
que parce que faut que je foutais faut
que je monte
il fait vraiment de bonne visualisation
du terrain et du jeu ce qui est pas
forcément facile à u16 et il arrive à
trouver l'homme libre et ça moi je
j'apprécie fortement pauvres surtout
pour un grand c'est quand même assez as
terreur et c'était à noter par ben dans
les points forts des vannes moblie sur
son scouting report mains de passeurs et
tu mets athlète atypique pour sa taille
alors explique pour les gens qui l'ont
pas vue jouer ces badges pour arracher
rien sur ce que me disait je serais
d'accord mais ce que j'aime beaucoup
c'est amassé c'est l'amélioration de la
vision en tant que passeur un cul parce
qu'au début de la saison il paniqué un
peu il recevait la prise à deux puis
essayer de se débarrasser du ballon mais
plus la saison avance et plus il a pris
ses aises eyes sous la pression
défensive puis il était capable de
jugement de se démarquer en passant
périmètre jeu c'est vraiment un aspect
chez lui qui m'a beaucoup plu aussi
athlète atypique c'est parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui a des proportions énormes
que les promotions suleymanov il est
très grave et les traits l'ont aussi
donc il couvre vraiment beaucoup de
terrain pour quelqu'un même pour
quelqu'un de sa taille
c'est vraiment juste très difficile de
jouer contre lui à al attaque parce que
c'est un top 10 tu fait trois pas il a
fait un historique avril c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un athlète aussi qu'ils
quitteraient ce qui est très fin qui
porte dans le contact qui pendant la
percussion mais qui est beaucoup dans le
dans le timing est dans le terminal à
longueur de keven durette
je ne compare pas un vain mot blake est
vendu insisté je crois que ce serait une
comparaison paresseuse mais je l' ai vu
souvent par exemple su parler des
rebonds offensifs
je les suis venu souvent étendre un bras
puis aller chercher deux derrière
quelques matchs il l'a fait je crois 2 3
fois contre colorado cette année c'était
sepa sepa dès des choses quelqu'un avec
un corps normal fait c'est quelqu'un qui
comprend que son corps est anormal vie
qui s'en sert de la bonne façon
donc c'est vraiment c'est pas le dos qui
saute le plus haut mais il a une
là une fluidité une vitesse que les gore
on passe appareil vraiment très bien
quelqu'un qui a un corps aussi long et
aussi étroit mais c'est le mot que
j'attendais fluidité manu ça se voit
aussi défensivement même si on le disait
il n'est jamais très loin du cercle du
fait de la défense de loi s'il était
jamais on tue l'imaginent défendre sur
plusieurs positions eux moi je le vois
bien je projette bien à terme dans cinq
ans mouais maintenir du 5 et du 4 pas
plus ah bon pas des petits les petites
heures c'est pour ça que j'ai regardé
des matches c'est je me voulait savoir
s'il arrivait à pouvoir tenir un peu la
cadence face à des joueurs qui lui
arrive plein de langues ou qui qui sont
arrêtés mais qui vont aller vers le
cercle
et il le fait rarement il arrive à le
faire quand même parce que sur un match
notamment ses arizona oui où il arriva
il se met quand même assez loin mais
comme baignade il a tellement des grands
segments que finalement il fait un pas
et il arrive à contrer le bonhomme mais
sur des sur la nba
chez je le vois tant en défense vraiment
nettement à tenir des meneurs arrières
hockey alan l année ce cri tu es
d'accord ou pas juste pour préciser j'ai
fait quelques petites recherches du que
tu m'as sur le guardian the way i see it
or donc taj est dit le 3 le meneur
titulaire qui est un transfert qui à 25
ans dont on se parle qui joue à santa
clara avant c'était 10 % de 16 % de
passes décisives et 11 % de pertes de
balles sur l'année c'est pas
exceptionnel pour ton bonheur ce sila 24
ans au moment où tu joues et droopy
personnes le transfert de rice qu'ils
ont pris aussi c'était 17% de positiver
15% de turnover donc quand tu es deux
intérêts étaient deux porteurs de balle
font autant que pertes de balle c'est
pas exceptionnel
c'est ce que je voulais mentionner sur
la défense serait un petit peu plus un
peu plus positif que
que manu je pense c'est un peu galvaudé
maintenant tout le monde veut que tous
les adhérents défendant switcher
d'études et font pas les meilleurs
joueurs excellents switcher sur le bas
courte était un petit peu raillé mais
c'est l'élite l'élite qui arrive à faire
ça moi je pense franchement qu'ils grâce
à sa mobilité de pied grâce à sa
mobilité de hanche qui montrent surtout
en attaque pour l'instant cirque hantise
tourner il arrive à tourner ben moi je
peux être qu'il pourra peut-être
transposer ça en défense et je pense
franchement barre s'il est comme j'ai
dit je vais beaucoup de zones ouest en
nba y en aura beaucoup moins je pensais
peut-être à les aiguiller les coaches
qui en font mais c'est plus sûr petites
séquences tout juste comme ça d'ailleurs
au passage dans cette zone là il était
super fort parce qu'en fait dire alors
qu'ils bloquaient un peu entre la zone
intermédiaire et le panier bas lui la
vénus à mettre son bras résister c'est
tellement long charger complètement la
géométrie comment l'équipe attaquer mais
en fait on l'a assez peu vues sur ba
voila ce pick and roll à sa ligne à
trois points
le porteur de balle face à lui mais je
pense franchement que wind à ilari ilari
va pas arrêter les les gros porteurs de
malfaçons personne n'arrête vraiment
mais je pense que franchement quand ils
se retrouvent à peut-être face à detroit
ou face à détroit 4 je pense qu'il
pourra vraiment faire un bon travail là
dessus et qui pourra pas dûment protégés
le cercle ce qui ce qui est ce qu'on lui
demande quand il ya ce genre de
situation parce qu'après que contesté
sur un step back ou sur un joueur qui
fermait de 80 mètres - 2 mètres et qu'il
ya angel de fou c'est trop compliqué
alors c'est intéressant le fait qu' il
défend des zones majoritairement du
temps là il va passer sur un modèle nba
où il devra devoir quoi qu'il arrive
couvrir plus de terrain et il y avait
une remarque assez constante de la part
de hugues de notre data team
qui disait que evans mot blé qui avait
des doutes sur evene mobley pas du fait
de son skill 7 qui est très complet mais
du fait de son moteur ben je te pose la
question à toi est ce que tu trouves que
bailly s'essouffle vite mais voilà il
manque de coffre
ouais jusqu'à un certain point je ne me
fais pas trop avec ça parce que je crois
que c'est une question de contexte ici
qui va changer immédiatement à un billet
je crois que ce point joueur qui fait
pour être utilisé comme on l'utilisé à
ios il sait pas on l'a vu au post up je
veux dire la seule chose qui sait bien
faire au post up s'est lancé laissez
passer le ballon mais non faut t motors
-3 côté désir côté côté côté poussé au
travers de la douleur je crois que je
crois pour les migrants joie de ses pics
sont minces parce que les blessures
viennent plus tard dans ce cas là c'est
à dire les blessures aux pieds les
blessures aux genoux comme ça ils sont
plus facilement sur plus facilement
épargné de soi puis le reste je crois
que c'est une question de contexte je
crois qu'ils sont ces événements blé à
un tir qui projette potentiellement
commettait une série de trois points en
nba si on développe ce côté là des mots
bis c'est là qu'on a un jour extrêmement
payant à nbc sports alpha le fais en
gros on passera sur son utilisation
après mais c'est bien que tu parles du
shoot manu que penses tu de son tir
qu'est ce que tu me qu'est ce qu'il y a
qu est ce qui te plaît pas qu'est ce qui
te plaît et comment tu le vois évoluer
moi j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup le
le tir c'est un tir qui par d'assez haut
que difficilement contrôlable même par
des pivots mais là ça me choque
rien qui me choque de trop dans tout ce
qu'il fait bon j'aime beaucoup c'est un
peu pour vous faire une image d ce
qu'ils au plus simple une fois un peu
comme garnett qui
qui parle un peu au dessus de la tête et
qui revient comme ça donc j'ai poussé
complètement incontrable pour des hommes
comme nous mais je le projet est
vraiment vraiment bien sûr avec du
travail et une bille est tout simplement
où il va faire beaucoup de tirs beaucoup
de tirs donc je n'ai pas de le point
négatif là comme ça à sortir de ce que
j'ai vu en tout cas parce que il est à
moins de 70% lancers francs sur 6
tentatives par match il est a
péniblement 30% à 3 points sachant qu'il
en prenait très peu de moyens les plus
d'un par match seulement
ouais un peu plus d'un par match ans et
demi alan toile le tir commençe comment
tu le vois évoluer pareil c'était plutôt
optimiste remaniement ouais tout est
optimiste c'est compliqué que des jeunes
quels sont les indications qui est plus
que les indications qui sont pas bonnes
celles 69% et 0 point qu'ils sont pas
one qui sont moyennes et ses 69 % aux
lancers francs
l'éducation qui sont bonnes c'est les
flashs la fluidité
le gie la gestuelle c'est réussi ça peut
être un peu galvaudé je trouve que la
sienne il ya là même aux lancers francs
il ya là même à trois points il a la
même quand il fait son petit turn around
the hunter qui maîtrise assez bien donc
oui j'achète j'achète sentir et puis de
toute manière à cette taille là les
joueurs qui tirent comme ça sont
tellement peu qu'il n'a pas besoin de
tourner à plus de 35% à 3 points pour
être déjà excellent dans ce domaine là
donc c'est vraiment surtout que en
réalité et sarah brandir un peu sur ce
que de ce qu'on disait sur le moteur ait
joué 34 p par match pour à l'intérieur à
son âge c'est vous pouvez peut-être
qu'il ya une certaine forme de fatigue
sur certaines prises de tirs sur sur le
lancer franc je regardais là il n'ya
même pas 10 me dit pivot en nba qui joue
aujourd'hui plus de 30 minutes
aucun billet ne jouera pas 33 minutes
les premières années le jour aux
alentours de 25 minutes
je pense que ça peut aussi l'aider à
gagner en
en dire en efficacité sur le tient le
l'indicateur le plus positif que je vois
au niveau du tir puisque je plonge dans
les statistiques pour vous 46% sur les
tupan jumper donc c'est les tirs à deux
points mais qui sont pas au cercle donc
un moins de plus un mètre cinquante qui
sont pas plus d'un mètre cinquante du
servent plus de deux mètres peut-être
donc c'est pas mal c'est pas mal du tout
c'est même très très bien ça veut dire
qu'il a un jeu à mi distance déjà déjà
développé effectivement si on fait des
comparaisons stats avance et on tombe
sur karl anthony temps wendell carter
jahren jackson bon marvin bagley un peu
plus loin si tu sais si tu es avec dans
la liste avec tardi jackson c'est quand
même extrêmement positif ouais ouais
ouais bah c c'est dans le même acabit
alors qu'arles anthony times et jermaine
jackson junior protéger mieux le cercle
j'ai une question sur deux aux tec en
forme de question pour ben finalement
est-ce que evans mobley contrairement à
ce qu'on pouvait penser en début d'année
va pas être un meilleur prospect
offensif que défensif
bon je suis pas sûr de ça moi je crois
que moi je crois que j'ai quand même des
réserves à propos du tir je trouve qu'il
tire beaucoup sur la pente descendante
quand il prend son repas sont chaudes
surtout son estimant son espèce de
jumper de 18 pieds qui va à peu près
partout dans tous les matches et ça me
fait penser qu'il vaut probablement être
le prochain président du nom non oui
club avec qu'elle nie
mais peut-être peut-être pas ce qui
s'est passé parce qu'il s'est il fait
rendre utile de plusieurs façons soit au
pot de bach soi ou compostés bas même
selon ces mêmes selon ces limitations
physiques mais on parle vraiment d'un
joueur ici qui ai fait ça faisait quand
même des limitations offensivement qu'il
faut utiliser selon certaines balises
donc défensivement
moi je suis vraiment pas inquiet qui va
toujours trouver une manière de se faire
valoir
aussi donc moi je voudrais pas paraître
plus défensivement la minorité non
c'était beau et qu'il y faisait mais
j'ai pas acheté chez manu ci voulait
rebondir sur cette question vous pouvez
mais j'enchaîne même manu je voulais te
faire parler du comportement ce que tu
as vu en plus tard vu là des matchs
spécialement pour le podcast est ce que
tu as vu des indicateurs positifs ou
négatifs
on sait que c'est subjectif souvent mais
ce sera peut-être un peu négatif c'est
ça ces retours entre 11 quand
l'adversaire est en transition où il
fait pas forcément les efforts il a par
la faune sera mon ca ou des foyers
il a même quand c'est pas forcément
transition il arrive après ses
coéquipiers alors que et les adversaires
donc c'est vrai c'est vraiment ça qui
m'a
sur les derniers matches que j'ai re rue
là c'est vraiment ça qui m'a sauté aux
yeux
autrement défensivement non à part ça
rien rien de trop choquant à part le
fait qu'ils se bat pas forcément
peut-être rebond suffisamment pour moi
oui il pourrait avec ses son envergure
sa taille pourrait dominer totalement et
je le trouve un peu un peu suffisant là
dessus notamment sur les prises de
position ce genre de chose il va pas un
fou
donc j'ai vraiment ces deux choses là
que je retiendrai alan savate énervé
donc je vais te la pose est est-ce qu'il
serait pas un peu soft
tu veux dire quoi qu'il arrive pas s'il
aime pas trop le contact avec les gens
depuis 2010 ouais il aime pas trop
chamailler quoi il est il n'aime pas la
bagarre ouais non non non non je suis
pas d'accord sa mère patrie franchement
je suis dit est ce que c'est une
mauvaise chose
c'est une mauvaise chose de ne pas
vouloir toujours se battre au rebond ça
oui je suis à sa guise et la dépression
ce que j'aime en son nom des maisons
paysannes
mais j'ai suivant atteindrait quant à
elle joué 34 8 par match
alors oui la zone aide à jouer le plus
longtemps sans se fatiguer je pense
romain explique reste un doute mieux que
moi mais moi quand on jouait 48 en zone
c'était plus facile que de jouer 40
minutes lundi
mais oui là il a encore à côté soft mais
je pense qu'il pâtit peut être au site
de son corps et de sa sa morphologie qui
ne l'aide pas encore est la question
parce qu'elle va donner ce qu'on peut
penser qu'il va de nouveau les peut
prendre
vingt kilos voilà la question 15,3 kg
est-ce qu'il a la mort faute le
morphotype pour vous reprendre ses kilos
la lrà vote à votre avis à ton avis je
suis pas physionomiste mais j'ai assez
bon espoir que sur le haut du corps il
puisse oui prendre en volume et en masse
sur le bas du corps mois sur les longues
les gens qui ont des longues les hanches
haute comme si comme disent certains ou
qui ont peut-être c'est peut-être ce
timbre et sans que c'est un ol en voilà
un but où il ya un vent trop bas par
rapport à des anges très haute
là ça peut être plus problématique parce
que c'est la prise de masse à pouvoir se
une prise de masse de ce que je sais je
n'ai pas d'autre chose
elle ne peut pas vraiment être ciblée en
fait quand on veut prendre du muscle ça
se fait un peu rire les gens nous
corrigeons dans les commentaires ça
pourrait être intéressant
je ne crois pas qu'on peut cibler un
endroit on veut prendre du muscle ou
prendre de la masse je pense qu'ils ont
fait c'est une globalité du corps fait
pourra prendre des kilos parce que on
s'entraîne un peu partout bien sûr on
peut mettre l'accent sur certaines
choses mais on peut pas je crois cible
est toujours très très bien ciblé à 100%
une partie donc en fait je me dis il va
falloir qu'il prenne de la masse partout
il a fait ça risque pas de polluer cette
fluidité
ça peut évoluer sur cette unité
offensive ça ne la polluent pas chez
anthony davis mon tennis et unicorn est
un joueur qui n'arrive qu'une seule fois
dans des dents dans l'histoire de la nba
donc il est plus fort mais déjà un katie
white et exactement quel que fût large
d'épaulés
ouais exactement donc avoir à voir mais
il va falloir qu'ils aient cette prise
de masse chez lui parce que la nba
aujourd'hui je veux pas ce s'intitule y
aura une pièce est jouée contre des
amendes et phénomène athlétique des
mutants donc il va se faire tanguer les
premières années c'est sur ce faire
tanguer se fait deux fois ses membres
oui ton expression comme dans un avion
comme dans un avion
ben tu parlais de kevin durant tout à
l'heure 4 qui est toujours faim qu'ils
étaient fin qui sera fin mais qui est
plutôt fort sur le bas du corps est ce
qu'on espère un développement comme ça
niveau
morphotype moi je dirais non
personnellement parce que je veux dire
on parle aussi d'un joueur que le projet
un problème avec la boîte son corps avec
les pieds avec les genoux qui en ont la
chine
donc je crois qu'un joueur quitte le
mans qui est un peu le plus grand plus
l'eau comme caméra de meubler ça serait
une recette pour un désastre non
peut-être coûté moi je trouve que quand
on parle d'un joie de ses pieds qui tire
beaucoup je trouve que la comparaison
paraît sûr c'est toujours de comparer à
chris bosh mais là je crois qu'ici on a
un vrai archer type selon lequel
développe et développer écrans de
mobiles et chris bosh est un tout petit
peu plus et peint sur le haut du corps
il ya pris beaucoup de muscles avec les
années mais il est encore temps qu'enfin
sur les jambes ce qui a permis d'avoir
[Musique]
une enquête oui il aurait pu s'il y
arrive le problème c'est qu'à retenir
des mormons des problèmes de poids il y
avait des d abc sur les planches quoi
ouais mais oui d'accord chris bosh
intéressant je viens de trouver des
stats au shoot high school messieurs pas
facile on est à 33% à 3 points en 4 ans
sur soixante sept tentatives uniquement
évidemment donc c'est faible mais il n'a
pas progressé mais il n'a pas régressé
non plus voilà ce que je peux vous dire
surtout que la ligne plus près on exclut
la ligne est plus proche effectivement
et aux lancers francs c'est pareil 70 %
exactement la même chose au visage 17
sait on sur 13 aux lancers francs dont
84%
ouais et il avait pris aucun trois
points tu tournes l'as olemps et france
intéressant parce que 264 tenté c'est
pas mal on ice collet
et 69% paraît donc a relativement peu de
progression quand même pour amener de
l'eau au moulin de deux bennes qui était
encore un peu sceptique sur le tir de
monsieur mobley je crois que l'on tire
romain l'était pas non plus bref on leur
demandera bon maintenant on va parler de
son rôle en nba
le probable en nba le rôle idéal
je veux commencer avec ben toi alan
comment on utilise au mieux dans ses
premières années pour à la fois exploité
ses forces et en développer d'autres ce
sera parce qu'en fait si on droite et
voit le mobile est dans le top 3 il faut
qu'ils arrivent à faire plus que ce
qu'on demande aux va dire au pivot
médian donc en nba
ce qui est déjà pas mal il va falloir
qu'ils apportent en fait simplement la
combinaison menace aux tirs sur pick'n
bob je pense que ça va être quelque
chose d'essentiel
tu l'as dis à mes distances c'est pas
mal cette année est aussi par flash
c'est bien à à trois points il va
falloir qu'ils protègent le cercle qui
est cette protection de cercle et
qu'ensuite bas cette qualité de passe
que ton manu par les dons ben est que
ben évoqué dans son profil qu'on a tout
vu on a tous vu evans mobley pris à deux
en situation de post up faire la passe
dans le corner ou dans le akkar
entraîneur et pour le tireur ou pour un
joueur qui coupait à l'opposé passe
extrêmement impressionnante toujours
dans le bon le bon tempo
on l'a tous vu faire ça ou on l'a même
vu j'ai mis un petit clip contre rock
c'est contre oregon où sweet sixteen il
est à idées en face du panier à ligne à
trois points il fait dribble sous la
jambe il part main gauche est passé et
il paraît passe de côté pour son frère
pour dengue et enfin un mec qui à 2 19
ans de deux mètres 2010 qui fait ça moi
personnellement j'en ai ras j'ai très
rarement vu donc en fait il va falloir
qu'ils protègent le cercle dont qu'il
soit utile qui pour beaucoup de géants
sur du pick and roll donc pour autant
que poseurs d'écran et ensuite par avec
ses qualités de passes ça lui permettra
de prendre des décisions
sur donc sur short roll donc quand il
pleut son meneur va lui donner la balle
pour qu'il fasse bien ça comme ça ce
sera utile pour des rails pour cliquer
pour les shooteurs dans les points
acquis tir parce que comme ça il va
qu'on pourra utiliser sur pick'n pay
lévis fera défensivement il protège le
cercle si la c3 choses là en plus d'un
développement musculaire qui nous
permettra potentiellement de jouer de
l'iso ou du post up c'est un ça il peut
il peut être un des cinq meilleurs
pivots de la ligue 1 jour le problème
c'est que il faut aussi toujours pensé
au fait que même si on voit tous les
prospects par le prisme de la réussite
ça n'arrive pas tout le temps et si elle
va de mobley n'arrive pas à développer
toutes ces choses là bien sa valeur de
remplacement elle est bien plus grande
que si john green challenge days scotty
banque ne veut pas tout ça parce que
alors pour les poste de pivot
ça sera un petit centre de trouver d or
qui pourront faire ça mais si on veut
être positif
il faut que voilà week-end pop pick and
roll du post up quo quand il aura pris
un peu de muscle et puis tour de
contrôle défense et voilà qu'ils soient
ce joueur qui change dont la géométrie
de l'attaqué adverse parce que ils
protègent de cercle et manu tu es
d'accord t'as des trucs à ajouter a
retiré non là du coup quoi il paraît
j'imagine et dans ma tête des actions de
bouc lopez milwaukee dans ce rôle là
comme ça de shooter qui peut s'éloigner
mais distance 3 points et le protecteur
de cercle ça ça lui va parfaitement
mais faut tout que ce que comme gala ne
faut que tout ce qui doit travailler
fonctionne à merveille mais c'est un
rôle là comme ça quand quoi il parlait
qui m'est venu instinctivement ans teddy
intéressant ben tu as une réaction oui
bah je crois que l'analyse est vraiment
un très complète
c'est vraiment ce côté petit côté pékin
pop mais qui doit pas non plus se fier
là dessus je crois je crois qu'ils
doivent à trouver des manières de se
trouver être d'être utile de différentes
façons un préalable au club
c'est pas un exemple que je déteste puis
je trouve complètement à voir comment et
pas de meubles et ajouter des arts que
celle des flèches à son arc à sa flèche
depuis quelques années bien confiance
qui je suis c'est marrant je suis pas
trop je peux trop d'accord je le vois
plus joué en fed cup je vois plus joués
4 en fait je ne vois plus jouer à côté
d'un gros je le vois presse courir
autour d'écrans evans mobley moi quand
je l'imaginé en nba
moi je trouve c'est un autre c'est c'est
un autre à autre comme potentiel et puis
je dirais six mois si je suis devant mon
blé j'apprends à faire les deux ce que
tu vois c'est ce que tu vas
offensivement mais défensivement
genevois protéger le cercle où je peux
moins polluants du panier édition c'est
difficile parce que c'est toujours cette
histoire d' eurobonds
si son équipe est vraiment moins forte
au rebond quand il est sur le terrain
est qui et qui pourra pas jouer cinq sur
de très longues durées en fait c'est
quand même très important rebond
défensif de rennes jackson par exemple
il ne joue pas ce qu on ne peut tout ce
qu'il joue 5
mais c'est pas possible mais à cause du
rebond et d'autres choses il toise
lionel messi mais comme il tire un tel
niveau
ça permet de jouer aux cartes avec des
baïonnettes à côté c'est ça c'est ça il
faudra te dire suis vraiment si tu veux
le faire jouer 4 je pense oui oui ah bah
oui mais mais c'est pour ça que si le
tir mais un peu de temps à venir il faut
trouver des solutions pour le mettre
dans des positions
voilà des petits pin down qu'on voyait
un temps kevin durant à avoir des petits
pin d'âne pour des mi-distance des
choses comme ça quoi
il sera efficace là dessus il serait
cassé ce qui renonce et le tir ne marche
pas en fait le genre qu'il faut à côté
ces banques lopez enfin il prévenu
pourra tirer à trois points et protéger
le cercle et lui pourra jouer le plus
proche du panier est pas vraiment être
un mondain que défensif euros bondissent
à de tous les intérieurs quoi 6 à partir
exactement et conclue mais il n'y a pas
beaucoup de broc lopez no fo boucle
opposé côté design on pourrait passer à
côté de tout manque toutefois serait
alors tu disais c'est très difficile ça
va être très difficile pour lui de
valoir son top 3 de draft vous l'avez
tous numéro deux dans votre classement
tous les trois je suis je crois que lui
seul peut avoir un numéro 2 tout
simplement
j'avais juste lire la réaction de nikos
matin qui peut plus être dans le podcast
quand je lui ai demandé qu'est ce que tu
as à dire sur evans mobley il a écrit
tous les débats autour de son physique
et du manque de poids c'est du bullshit
il va être monstrueux voilà on sait pas
une analyse développée mais je suis sûr
qu'il leur ait eue s'il avait été là
mais en tout cas ni qu ils croient vous
y croyez aussi tous les trois vous le
prenez deuxième vous le prenez devant
green devant secondes pourquoi 30
secondes chacun
ben tu commences bail parce que
plusieurs équipes à qui manque un joueur
comme ça en bas de la draft à détroit
kyi qui souffrait plusieurs années dans
ce domaine je crois que 6e plus ou moins
de joueurs de cette qualité là à sa
petite taille là que j'ai vu ici très
serré pour moi mais je voudrais ici si
je suis un des trois sur houston si je
suis un
je sais plus trop qui l'a peut-être pas
peut-être pas minnesota je crois que moi
je pointe deuxième opération manu parce
qu'il ya trop de belles choses à
travailler potentiellement il peut
quasiment tout faire et pour moi c'est
vraiment le truc qui fait que
en fait même si l'embellie une chose il
va il va travailler sur quatre autres et
même ça ça va le rendre incroyable et on
a pressé que du que du potentiel c'est
pile ou face depuis deux mois mais pour
moi y'a trop de belles choses à
travailler
ça peut devenir un produit monstrueux
alan moi je pense qu'en fait avant le
jour du drame j'aurais green devant
personnellement de plus en plus de ce
côté là parce que le guardian angels and
green pour potentiellement ça peut être
incroyable pour une attaque une bille et
je pense mais van gogh lait devant seul
devant kumming à devant barnes devant
tous les autres parce que et pour une
fois c'est rare pour nous avec à
l'intérieur mais parce qu'en fait il a
potentiellement tout y'a pas un truc où
il a d'ailleurs c'est moi la protection
de serques la défense occupe 6 si tout
va bien il a le tir la passe le dribble
voilà ces cinq choses là qui font que il
faut le cap des 5 ans veloso qui font
qu'un jeu peut sélectionner à
l'intérieur dans le top 5 ce que n'avait
pas wiseman ce que n'avait puisqu'il n'a
ce que n'avait pas helton selon moi donc
je n'aurais pas pris à cette place là et
donc ce cas potentiels votre mobile on
est sur du potentiel il a 20 ans mais
potentiellement ils à ces cinq choses la
série qui la pile 20 ans j'ai oublié de
mentionner il 2001 est ce que vous
l'avez un d'autres vous la halle à
envisager dans le même tiers que kyle
cunningham
non non parce que c'est trop incertain
ou est ce que c'est une question de plus
le niveau plancher ou de niveau
potentiel de position pour moi oyee oh
oui oui oui de de valeur par rapport à
la position je crois que les canines
gamme et le joie le type de joueur le
plus recherché déjà sait déjà que tout
ce que j'ai bac qui a besoin de faire il
fait bien très bien
voulez vous ajouter quelque chose sur le
dossier van moblie qu'on aurait oublié
al hamdania pas le crois qu'il ya moins
qu'un que williams mais quelques petits
pépins de santé je crois à je me
rappelle que quand il avait été au
tournoi u 19 avec kate winslet ou lui la
page ou de la compétence qu'il était là
mais je crois que c'est
il y avait des petits soucis de
blessures gens qu'il a été aussi
peut-être un peu blessé une cette
dernière année de lycée
oui à la facturation seniors en entier
c'est ça ça reste à surveiller quand
même surtout pour un grand mais il ya eu
aucune blessure étant sur l'année
l'année fraîche managua si ça par contre
oui effectivement
manu quelque chose à ajouter ou pas nos
cartes blanches non et ben non non non
c'est on le pense qu'on a pas mal fait
aux deux joueurs croient qu'il ya
plusieurs types une très large
fourchette de deux futurs possibles pour
lui je veux dire c'est pas il faut pas
nécessairement nécessairement réussi ou
échoué il va arriver à quelque part
entre les deux oui mais mais il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de futurs possibles
pour lui mais moi j'y crois moi je crois
que le profil physique
voilà une des premières choses que
recherchent un joueur c'est d'avoir un
profil physique domine a initié ce à
dire d'avoir l'air de flotter par dessus
le mais le match puis c'est quelque
chose que brendan ingram avait beaucoup
quand j'étais ado je vaux je vois ce
beaucoup à grenoble on espère qu'il aura
aussi cette grande fourchette pour
prendre ce fameux poids dont il a besoin
selon vous pour pour aller un peu plus
loin pour être un peu plus solides
notamment rebond quai
une de ses seules vraies faiblesses pour
le moment défensif puisque c'est un
joueur qui est très fin mais il n'a que
20 ans et on vous le rappelle il sera
peut-être pas forcément ultra performant
dès l'année prochaine mais un joueur ça
se projette sur trois quatre cinq ans
d'ailleurs manu 10 aides en 50 quand il
parlait tout à l'heure voilà c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut avoir en tête
aussi canton canton draft quelqu'un ou
quand on projette comme nous ont tous un
grand surtout un grand effectivement
effectivement ouais c'est beaucoup plus
avant on pensait que je taisais de coupe
à l'exploit penser que c'est surtout le
poste de meneur qui était le plus dur
d'entrée en nba
maintenant cette chose de grand on l'a
vu avec et les premiers pas des tonnes
de wendell carter de wiseman
tu peux être hyper talentueux tu peux
avoir plein de qualités on va te faire
sortir du terrain on va peut être en
difficulté parce que le pick and roll et
tout ça est dur donc faudra pas être
trop dur si les gens durant les deux
prochains débats de mots bleus sont un
petit peu déçue mais c'est tout à fait
normal
vous avez le droit à une réponse chacun
une uniquement qu'elle est dans le top
10 cela votre destination préférentielle
dans le top 10 des destinations au
départ dont des tables choix de grave
donc les 10 contre plus de chances de
choper le premier choix votre
destination préférentielle pour evans
noblet que c'est juste ok si pourquoi
tony huston et toronto toronto très très
belle cote ah ouais toronto oui ok si
houston n'auront pas mais très bien et
ben jannet on achète on remballe merci
beaucoup monsieur merci
et à bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
sur envergure on vous envoie sur
envergure penser aux pour le big board
pour les scouting report bonnet vous à
votre plateforme d'e coûte à notre
chaîne youtube et et envoyez nous des
coeurs on adore à coeur bisous tout le
monde ciao